all right Tyrone what we can talk about
today hey how you doing man you know I
was so that's that depression man
when my bike got stolen man I got so
depressed because I tripped on myself
because I was so dependent
on a v on on a bike I could move uh I I
my phone had left my phone it just
seemed like I was just lost you know I
mean I went home
took my medication and slept and ate I
didn't take a shower for four days
I was smelling myself in my own room
and that's bad and I did I still didn't
want to get up I just want to I just
wanted to just have
I didn't I just I got that feeling that
I would love I just I just my mind just
took me there
my and you know how sometimes when I be
I'll be tripping out my mind blocks
stuff off and then next thing you know
it helped me come back
and the man just takes over
and I was so scared that I got so
depressed man I was in my bed I didn't
want to live anymore
and I started thinking about other
people that died around me man
when they give up
and I'm like man you try to give out I
got that feeling I just want to give up
I was useless
I ain't supposed to be here no more
it's just I just love and I stayed in
that bed man I stayed in the bed
and
I didn't want to get up to the restroom
man the P I want the P I was just so
I was scared of myself
I didn't want to go nowhere man
you know she did she called my brother
in Atlanta my brother in Atlanta had his
kids his four daughters talked to me his
wife talked to me
hey how you doing I'm all right
and I wasn't all right
I'm never all right
don't make it seem all right look man I
had no drugs I had nothing my sister and
that pain hit me and it hurted
you're not even feel no pain well I'm
gonna feel painful
I thought I was doing all right I
thought I was making some progress
it did and then it took me back
it took me all the way back man
right back where I came from
to be back where I came from my mind my
mind did this to me man
he took me right back
and I didn't want to go there and it
went on his own man
they went on your own mind over matter
that's [__] your mind takes over
wherever you go it's too sad I got two
sides to me man I Dance with the Devil a
whole lot when I don't want to dance
with them
I only want to dance with the Devil but
sometimes I enjoy that [__] man
and the devil is so Insidious man these
things to me his face to me and I listen
in my own voice
man I want I just want to give up I just
want to die that day I was in my bed
curled up man I didn't know what to do
I didn't know what to do man I really
did and I never felt like that before I
never put my mind in that state before
I don't know what to do
I didn't know what to do man
I used to call Mama and your voice she
said if they're gonna be all right I
will believe it
it's gonna be all right
I could even talk to you on the phone
man
oh did you get upset Jesus help help me
as long as she comes to help me
and she called my brother my mother
called me
his daughter's talking to me you might
talk to me oh
I know what to do man
I got lost once again
[Applause]
and then I was doing all right man when
I was lost once again
I guess I know I yearn for the pain but
that face hit me so hard
you know what I want to go up here
I want to give away I don't want to do
it
I got I got to call the people call me
okay okay
I gotta go
and then I had to go man because my man
was taking me there you know man it
never took me there before on this old
man I knew that might take me over his
own
baby dude I don't want to do man
right
but I had someone I had so much I had so
much drugs in my system then I tried to
slow down
and then things start happening then I
didn't expect to happen
why did I get so depressed about a bike
got stolen from me because I
I left my phone I was just seems so lost
I didn't know what to do
I don't know if you understand that man
I was there I always do if you
understand it I was lost
I was lost man
56 years old long
unfortunately I was in my room I was in
the streets man they would have ate my
ass up
they would hate me up live
yeah
I've been feeling like the whole I just
feel like Obama [__] everybody's just
my mind just takes over me
and it's hard it's hard when your mind
just takes over
and it make you do stuff you don't want
to do man
I won't know why did I go there
why did I want to give up why I want to
die I didn't
mean
at that very time in that moment
everyone will be in no more
pain hit me so hard man that Depression
hit me so hard I was depressed
and I didn't want to be feeling like
that no more
man I called you mark man
I
I appreciate you man
I'll be trying to bug you with that man
I appreciate you
I really do man
sometimes I might get away
I don't know man I thought I was all
right Mom
that I was doing all right man you know
what I'm saying but I betrayed that hit
me so hard I believe in my I believe in
my goddamn self
I really believe my whole life
I was doing all right
but man had to bring me back to reality
cause I'm still 140 and one foot out
I ain't going nowhere
my mind brought me back to reality is
that reality hurt it hurted because I
didn't expect that
ain't that me to bring me back to me
brought me back to me
made me realize where I met
or what I can end up back at or where I
can go to it's hard to make decisions
your life man the right decision they
say well you know better you do better
okay I accept that in the long run not
now
I ain't gonna do better now
but I want to do better and it I want to
do better man
I really do
but mine just had me Dance with the
Devil Man
and you make it seem so fun
he he takes the pain from me
everything but I'm killing myself man
slowly
the devil just let me go do what I want
to do and I'm thinking I'm getting away
I ain't getting away nowhere
because you put people in my path just
like the man other the spirit put people
in my path to help me
myself I stagnate myself my mind
I stagnate myself
and when I Dance with the Devil he
danced right with me and he's smiling
and I'm smiling and I don't even know it
I'm thinking did the pretty ass girl got
a big old booty
then I'm the man
and that's I'm dancing with the devil
because they're doing exactly what he
want me to do
she will
I got to learn I got to figure out me
I'm still trying to learn me Mark
I don't know me
because [__] hit me and I'm being
sometime
if you hit me before I ain't gonna Bend
because I'm I'm used to this [__] but
[__] hit me down used to I'm a beard
I'm fragile
I can't even touch my feelings
I won't deal with no goddamn feelings
I'm a man man don't deal with Phyllis
man be a man well I was taught
but you can't feel you can't hear but
over I ain't trying to heal right now
you know better you do better let me do
better later cause I heal like I ain't
standing here right now
foreign
go through whatever you need to go
through I'm going through it but it
still hurts so don't tell me that
[__]
everybody's bad I ain't made like
everybody
a lot of people ain't made it like me
but some people can't do the [__] I do
out there and I can't do so many [__]
people do out there
so
when I know better I do better but
that's later on
right now I'm trying to deal with myself
I'm still learning myself
thank you still learning myself man
and I thought I was I thought I thought
I was getting to know me
but when I'm by myself
I'm getting high using so how can I get
to know myself and I'm getting high with
myself because that's all I know
I don't know me
every place I go down every place I go
home every place I go to Pasadena I put
on an image I get it together
wherever I go I get into character
defend my role
how do I act like this when I go up
there to go go to my face oh I like this
when I go to Pastor dick I don't act
like this I get into character wherever
face I go
I'm a captain
so I still don't know me
but I sure got a lot of characters I
know that much
to fit in get in where I fit in it
bet you that much
I never been hit that hard with
depression whatever
never allow myself to get the hit like
that because I always stay academic
filled with that [__]
and a few days fatty without that [__]
that [__] hurts when you're used to it
we used to drinking water every day we
used to eat every day every day
and when you don't eat something wrong
you don't feel right you know do you
know why you don't feel right find it I
don't feel right
okay
I want to feel right so I want to know I
know how to feel right is do what I do
really get this on man I love this song
so much pain in my soul
I love that song because I can relate to
it I can identify to it pain
I use other people that's in my circle
that's in my life that's about a circle
help me people I got people helping me
get through what I'm going through
I ain't gonna put you in my circle and
if you can't help me I need you to help
me
when sometimes when I can't help myself
so don't get mad at me sometime hey man
I got love for you man I appreciate you
but you know I'm still trying to learn
how to do better
and it comes retirement I mean no harm
to nobody I appreciate y'all and uh
I hope she talked to you again thank you
bye